I'm rooting for Ryan all the way I'm a
homer I'm biased run is my boy I think
you can't get it done I think they do
run this fight back two or three times
there's a lot of other guys out there
that we want to see Ryan Garcia fight
and I think Ryan has that personality
like the old school guys where they make
fights happen that the fans want to see
that's why I like Ryan for box and be
better for Ryan one he's down to make
those fights happen whatever it takes
just so the fans see who's the best
because they have these belts but they
haven't fought the top guys they just
haven't Ryan's down to make that happen
when boxing they run from each other
it's the problem with boxing Ryan
Garcia's Cut From a Different Cloth he's
been doing this since he was seven